I wonder if that applies to pro-lifers
well we'll check later I'll send the
White House joining me now is New Jersey
Congressman Jeff Van Drew and Xavier
derusso prageru personality thank you
both for being here Congressman Kamala
Harris made a beeline for Tennessee to
chastise the house but she failed to
attend even one of the funerals of the
six slain individuals including three
children from last week your thoughts on
all of this my thoughts number one it's
the first time I've seen Kamala Harris
take a B-Line to go anywhere to do
anything the only thing she should be
doing is if she wants to is to teach
people how to be the worst vice
president in the history of the United
States of America that was shameful I
mean they were so worried about January
6th but here we have not just people not
just constituents not just average folks
but we have legislators who are part of
a gang philosophy and carrying on
inappropriately and breaking down the
halls of the State House that's wrong
she should never be supporting that and
you know what it's so typical of the
ultra liberals so typical it's okay for
us to do things but never for you yeah
that's what she was doing I'm just
disappointed in her and that's pretty
hard for me yeah well the the double I
don't like the double double standard I
have one rule for everybody and Xavier
uh these congressmen they weren't just
expelled because people didn't like them
they were expelled because they violated
the house rules of decorum now these two
congressmen are saying that this is
racist okay and the media is going along
with this narrative now the reason for
this is the third white congresswoman
who joined them in the protest was
spared watch the media reaction I want
your reaction
it's racism it's a double standard in
our society obviously I don't have to
say I would doubt they would have done
this to White members when you see the
racism like that just out in the open it
does you know take your breath away this
kind of blatant racism is what is going
to backfire on them
Xavier is this racism or members being
held accountable for violating State
House Rules
you know it's typical leftist Behavior
to just totally deflect and put
everything on racism this is called
holding them accountable because we've
already seen the left has no problem
burning down buildings if they're not
getting what they want and if we don't
start holding these lawmakers
accountable then our Democratic Republic
is just going to turn into a battle of
who can lead the bigger protests people
need to stop treating our Capitol
Buildings as if they're Section 8
housing we need to start having
accountability and we need to start
looking at the left and questioning what
are their priorities for Kamala Harris
to not have time to attend any funerals
or to even meet the families of these
victims but she does have time to push
the agenda of the left to take away our
constitutional rights to guns and to
make sure that she's keeping these far
left lawmakers into position of power
they do not care about you and I they
care about their agenda what we're
seeing cops in the in the state house in
Tennessee being jostled and pushed last
time I checked this was called an
Insurrection congressman we had images
like this is this another case of
activists feeling that their personal
Crusade trumps any rules of decorum or
even decent etiquette absolutely it's an
Insurrection if you do it but if we do
it it's really what's required and needs
to be done Kamal Harris didn't is never
visits veterans has never worried about
what happened to the families of the
Afghans that were lost in battle the
Americans that were lost in Afghanistan
never worried about our border went
there once didn't do anything at all
isn't protecting our country yet this
she runs over to is she a vice president
or is she a political hack I think she
behaved a lot more like a political hack
here it's disappointing to see that
whatever party you are well uh what
breaks my heart is is you have people
who are caught in the middle of this and
when you have a community Suffering The
Way Nashville is I have friends there
the first impulse should be
be with those who are grieving these
children who who never asked to to be
shot during the school day tend to that
then move to the politics but here they
move right to the politics and demonize
people it's the worst thing you can do
in a community they won't even talk
about it yeah they won't even talk
Xavier I want to give you the last word
on this as you watch this play out your
thoughts on what we're seeing here and
what we what the takeaway should be
the takeaway is that the less priorities
are all backwards and once again they
are capitalizing on trauma and they are
capitalizing on death to push an agenda
because they do not compare or they do
not care about us they only care about
what benefits them it's heartbreaking
thank you both for being here
Congressman Xavier happy Easter thank
you both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else